.
THESE GUNS SAID WERE THE THINGS
THAT CHANGED THE DYNAMIC FOR
HIM.
>> OKAY.
WE HAVE BREAKING NEWS.
THIS IS STEVE BANNON JUST
LEAVING THE FEDERAL COURTHOUSE
IN WASHINGTON, D.C.
AFTER HIS FIRST APPEARANCE AFTER
HE WAS CHARGED WITH TWO CRIMINAL
COUNTS OF CONTEXT OF COURT.
WE SAW HIM A COUPLE OF HOURS AGO
GOING INTO THIS COURTHOUSE AND
NOW HE IS LEAVING.
WE'LL SEE IF HE HAS ANYTHING
MORE TO SAY TO REPORTERS.
>> BANNON HERE, PROSECUTORS
DIDN'T SEEK TO DETAIN HIM BEFORE
HIS TRIAL.
BUT WE KNOW IS COMING AND BOND
WAS SET AND HIS OFFICIAL
ARRAIGNMENT IS NEXT WEEK.
BUT WE HEARD FROM THIS MORNING
SPEAKING ABOUT THE PROCEEDINGS
TODAY WAS NOISE AS HE CALLED IT,
OF COURSE, BANNON REVELS IN THIS
ATTENTION.
LET'S SEE WHAT WE HEAR FROM
STEVE BANNON.
>> WHERE IS DAVID?
>> RIGHT HERE.
>> LISTEN, ORDINARY WE DON'T
LIKE TO KPLCOMMENT ON THE CASE
I HAVE FLN OBLIGATION TO
SOMETHING ATTORNEY GENERAL
GARLAND WROTE, HE PROMISED
JUSTICE DEPARTMENT OOEXS WOULD
SHOW THEY ADHERE TO THE RULE OF
LAW AND FOLLOWS THE FACTS AN LAW
AND PURSUED EQUAL JUST ALONG THE
LAW.
I ASSUME YOU COULD TAKE OFF YOUR
MASKS.
DO IT.
IT IS A FREE COUNTRY.
THERE IS NOTHING ABOUT THIS CASE
THAT REFLECTS A PURSUIT OF THE
EQUAL JUSTICE UNDER THE LAW.
THIS THING WAS A SCAM FROM THE
BEGINNING.
THE COMMITTEE -- THE
COMMITTEE -- COMMITTEE THAT WAS
CONVENED HERE WAS CONVENED
EXCLUSIVELY OF PEOPLE WHO HAVE
MADE PREJUDGMENTS AND ANNOUNCED
THEM PUBLICLY.
THE CHAIR OF THE COMMITTEE SUED
PRESIDENT TRUMP PERSONALLY AND
BEFORE HE WAS EVEN APPOINTED TO
HIS POSITION DETERMINED AND PUT
IN WRITING THAT PRESIDENT TRUMP
WAS RESPONSIBLE FOR THE EVENTS
OF JANUARY 6.
THIS IS NOT AN INVESTIGATIVE
COMMITTEE.
THERE IS NOTHING TO INVESTIGATE
WHEN HE'S MADE A PREJUDGMENT.
OTHER MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
ANNOUNCED THEIR PREJUDGMENTS
WELL IN ADVANCE.
IT IS NOT EQUAL JUSTICE UNDER
THE LAW MR. GARLAND TO CHARGE A
MATTER LIKE THIS CRIMINALLY.
THE HOLDER OF THE PRIV LIBLG IN
THIS CASE, EXECUTIVE PRIVILEGE
INVOKED THE PRIVILEGE.
STEVE BANNON IS A LAY PERSON.
WHEN THE PRIVILEGE HAS BEEN
INVOKED BY THE PURPORTED HOLDER
OF PRISON VILEGE, YOU HAVE NO
CHOICE.
YOU CAN'T PUT THE JEANNIE BACK
IN THE BOTTLE.
MR. BANNON ACTED AS HIS LAWYER
AND COUNSELED HIM BY NOT
APPEARING AND NOT TURNING OVER
DOCUMENTS IN THIS CASE.
HE DIDN'T REFUSE TO COMPLY.
HE MADE QUITE CLEAR THAT IF A
COURT ORDERED HIM TO COMPLY, HE
WOULD DO THAT.
BUT HE HAD AN OBLIGATION TO
HONOR THE PRIVILEGE THAT WAS
INVOKED AND IN TERMS OF
PROSECUTING THIS CRIMINALLY, IT
VIOLATES SETTLE DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE POLICY THAT IS BINDING
ON THE EXECUTIVE BRANCH.
IT IS OUTRAGEOUS THAT A CRIMINAL
CHARGE WAS BROUGHT IN THIS CASE.
IT IS A MISDEMEANOR.
BUT IT IS BEING TREATED AS IF IT
WERE A CAPITOL CASE.
MR. BANNON TAKES THIS VERY
SERIOUSLY.
IT IS OUTRAGEOUS WHAT THE
GOVERNMENT DID.
THE PRIPS PELLS OF EQUAL JIFTS
UNDER LAW THAT ATTORNEY GENERAL
GARLAND SPEAKS ABOUT ARE VITALLY
IMPORTANT TO US AND WE ALL LOSE
WHEN THEY ARE SELECTIVELY USED
AND THEY VIOLATE THESE SIMPLES.
>> YSEE THE GUYS SAYING
INSURRECTION.
IT IS FREE SPEECH.
THEY HAVE THEIR OPINIONS.
HANG ON.
THIS IS THE MISDEMEANOR FROM
HELL FOR MERRICK GARLAND AND
NANCY PELOSI AND JOE BIDEN.
JOE BIDEN ORDERED MERRICK
GARLAND TO PROSECUTE ME FROM THE
WHITE HOUSE LAWN WHEN HE GOT OFF
MARINE ONE.
AND WE'RE GOING TO DO GO ON THE
OFFENSE.
WE'RE TIRED OF PLAYING DEFENSE,
WE'RE GOING ON THE OFFENSE ON
THIS AND STAND BY.
BY THE WAY, BY THE WAY, YOU
SHOULD UNDERSTAND NANCY PELOSI
IS TAKEN ON DONALD TRUMP AND
STEVE BANNON, SHE OUGHT TO ASK
HILLARY CLINTON HOW THAT TURNED
OUT FOR THEM.
WE'RE GOING ON THE OFFENSE.
STAND BY.
YOU SHOULD BE OUTRAGED IF HE
EVER FACED THAT POSSIBILITY.
AS AN AMERICAN.
THERE IS NOTHING CRIMINAL ABOUT
ANY CONDUCT THAT OCCURRED IN
THIS CASE AND WHEN WE RESPOND TO
MERRICK GARLAND, WE SAY APLEW
THE LAW EQUALLY.
WHO ELSE DID THEY PROSECUTE FOR
INVOKING EXECUTIVE PRIVILEGE IN
A CRIMINAL PROSECUTION?
READ THE DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE
OFFICE OF LEGAL COUNCIL LETTERS,
IT IS UNCONSTITUTIONALLY
ACCORDING TO THEM AND INCLUDING
BY THE RAY, READ THE OFFICE OF
LEGAL COUNSEL OPINION BY ERIC
HOLDER FROM THE FAST AND FURIOUS
CASE.
THIS IS UNHEARD OF TO FORCE A
PERSON TO VIOLATE THE INVOCATION
OF EXECUTIVE PRIVILEGE, BY THE
WAY, I MEAN THE COURT HASN'T
RULED YET IN PRESIDENT TRUMP'S
CASE VERSUS THOMPSON.
BUT EVEN BEYOND THAT THE
OPINIONS MAKE CLEAR THAT IT
MAKES SENSE BECAUSE WE OFTEN SEE
FORMER OFFICIALS KEPT IN ITS
LOOP.
THAT THE PRESIDENT NEEDS TO
CONSULT WITH AND WHATEVER YOU
HAPPEN TO THINK THE PRESIDENT --
PRESIDENT TRUMP TALKED ABOUT AT
THE TIME, THAT IS WHAT EXECUTIVE
PRIVILEGE EXISTS FOR.
SO PEOPLE COULD SPEAK FREELY
WITH THE PRESIDENT AND TALK
ABOUT STRATEGY MATTERS AROUND
TALK ABOUT NATIONAL SECURITY AND
OTHER IMPORTANT MATTERS.
>> BY THE WAY, BY THE WAY NOT
JUST TRUMP PEOPLE OR
CONSERVATIVES.
EVERY PROGRESSIVE AND EVERY
LIBERAL IN THIS COUNTRY THAT
LIKES FREEDOM OF SPEECH AND
LIBERTY, OKAY, SHOULD BE
FIGHTING FOR THIS CASE.
THAT IS WHY I'M HERE TODAY.
FOR EVERYBODY. I'M NEVER GOING
TO BACK DOWN AND THEY TOOK ON
WRONG GUY THIS TIME, OKAY.
THEY TOOK ON THE WRONG GUYS.
>> WHY DID YOU --
>> BECAUSE HE WAS INSTRUCTED BY
HIS ATTORNEY NOT TO SHOW UP IN
CONGRESS.
A LAY PERSON HAS TO FOLLOW HIS
ATTORNEY'S ADVICE.
IN MY VIEW AT LEAST.
WHEN HE'S FACED WITH A SUBPOENA,
HE DOESN'T KNOW ANYTHING ABOUT
LEGAL PROCESS OTHER WISE.
HE RELIES ON A LAWYER AND THE
LAWYER GAVE THE ADVICE AND I
MUST SAY RELY ON THE OFFICE OF
LEGAL COUNSEL OPINIONS WHICH
VERY CLEARLY SAY HE NEED NOT
SHOW UP.
>> DID HE GET BAD ADVICE?
>> NO.
THERE IS NO OTHER CHOICE.
ONE THE PRIVILEGE IS INVOKED,
SHOW UP AND TESTIFY AND BY THE
WAY THEY ASKED TO HAVE -- IF HE
WERE TO TESTIFY, TO HAVE THOSE
PEOPLE INVOKING THE PRIVILEGE A
REPRESENTATIVE OF THE PERSON
INVOKING THE PRIVILEGE PRESENT
JUST TO BE ABLE TO MONITOR IT
AND MAKE AN OBJECTION IF A
PRIVILEGE THE MATTER CAME UP.
THEY REFUSED TO ALLOW THAT.
ABOUT.
>> BY THE WAY, IF THE
ADMINISTRATIVE STATE WANTS TO
BRING ME ON, BRING IT.
AND WE'RE GOING TO GO ON
OFFENSE.
AND YOU STAND BY AND WE'RE GOING
TO SEE HOW WE'RE GOING ON
OFFENSE.
ALL OF THEM.
>> WHAT DO YOU MEAN -- WHAT HE
MEANS BY OFFENSE IS WE'RE GOING
TO CHALLENGE THIS AFFIRMATIVELY.
WE'RE GOING TO FIGHT TO DEFEND
HIS RIGHTS AN YOUR RIGHTS
ALREADY.
>> YOUR RIGHTS.
>> I REPRESENTED THE AMERICAN
CIVIL LIBERTIES UNION FOR MORE
THAN 20 YEARS AN ALL OF THE
ALLEGATION IN ALABAMA, THIS IS
AN ISSUE THAT THE AMERICAN CIVIL
LIB ERPTS UNION AULT TO BE ON
OUR SIDE WITH.
>> ALL RIGHT.
WE HAVE TO GO.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
>> SIR YOU SAID THAT ALL HELL
WOULD BREAK LOOSE --
>> YOU HEARD THE REMARKS FROM
STEVE BANNON AFTER THIS FIRST
APPEARANCE.
ALSO FROM HIS ATTORNEY DAVID
SHOWN.
STEVE BANNON CALLING THIS HE
SAID IT IS THE MISDEMEANOR FROM
HELL.
REFERENCING ATTORNEY GENERAL
MERRICK GARLAND AND NARNCY PELOI
AND JOE BIDEN AND HILLARY
CLINTON SO CLEARLY THE MAN
VERSUS THE ADMINISTRATION IS THE
ONE THAT HE WANTS TO FOLLOW.
LET'S BRING IN EVAN PEREZ AND
RYAN NOBLES WITH US ELIE HONIG
ON SET.
TELL US WHAT HAPPENED INSIDE OF
THAT COURTROOM?
>> Reporter: YEAH, VICTOR, THAT
WAS A NAME CHECK OF ALL OF THE
GREATEST HITS IF YOU ARE STEVE
BANNON AND YOU HAVE A PODCAST
AND YOU NEED TO FUND RAISE,
RIGHT.
AND SO THAT IS ONE OF THE THINGS
THAT YO
THAT YOU HEARD FROM HIM JUST NOW
IN COURT.
HE WAS OBVIOUSLY A LOT
DIFFERENT.
HE ANSWERED RESPECTFULLY TO THE
JUDGE WHEN THE JUDGE ADVISED HIM
OF HIS RIGHTS, THE JUDGE
SCHEDULED HIS ARRAIGNMENT FOR
LATER THIS WEEK BEFORE THE TRIAL
JUDGE AND JUDGE WHO IS ACTUALLY
GOING TO HEAR THIS CASE.
AND THEN HE WAS RELEASED ON HIS
OWN, THEY TOOK AWAY HIS
PASSPORT, THEY SAID, BUT HE IS
FREE TO GO AND HAS TO ABIDE BY
CERTAIN RESTRICTIONS WHILE HE'S
OUT.
BUT, LOOK, AS YOU COULD TELL,
FROM THAT LITTLE PRESS
AVAILABILITY JUST NOW, THIS IS
NOT A NORMAL CASE.
THIS IS NOT GOING TO BE A NORMAL
CASE BY ANY STRETCH OF THE
IMAGINATION.
NOT MANY SHOW UP TO THE FBI TO
TURN THEM IN WITH A LIVE STREAM
CREW BEHIND THEM.
HE IS HERE WITH HIS OWN
PRODUCTION CREW, THEY'RE ABOUT
TO WALK OUT JUST A FEW YARDS
AWAY TO SOME SUVs TO HIS HOME
WHERE HE DOES HIS PODCAST FROM.
AURND COULD TELL ALSO THAT YOU
SAID THIS IS NOT GOING TO BE AN
EASY CASE FOR THE JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT AND I THINK THAT IS
ONE OF THE INDICATIONS AN RUN OF
THE REASONS WHY DESPITE THE
FRUSTRATION FROM A LOT OF
PEOPLE, THE JUSTICE DEPARTMENT
TOOK SOME TIME, THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL AND THE U.S. ATTORNEY
HERE IN WASHINGTON TOOK THEIR
TIME IN CONSIDERING THIS
REFERRAL FROM THE HOUSE BEFORE
THEY MADE A DECISION ON FRIDAY
TO BRING THIS CRIMINAL CASE,
RIGHT.
AS BANNON HAS POINTED OUT, THERE
IS DECADES OF JUSTICE DEPARTMENT
INTERNAL LEGAL GUIDANCE THAT HE
BELIEVES SUPPORTS HIS IDEA THAT
HE DIDN'T HAVE TO STHOW UP, HE
COULD RELY ON THE FORMER'S
PRESIDENT'S CLAIM THAT HE IS
PROTECTED BY EXECUTIVE
PRIVILEGE.
SOME OF THAT WILL HAVE TO BE
WORKED OUT BEFORE THE COURT.
>> THANK YOU.
ELIE, WHAT ABOUT THAT.
IT WAS INTERESTING TO SEE THAT
HE WAS VERY DIFFERENT INSIDE OF
THE COURT.
HE WAS RESPECTFUL TO THE YOUNG
AND THEN HE COMES OITS AND THERE
IS ALWAYS THAT MEASURE OF BANNON
BLUSTER AND MARTYRDOM THAT HE
LIENS INTO.
BUT WHAT ABOUT HIS ARGUMENT THAT
THE EXECUTIVE PRIVILEGE ISSUE
HASN'T BEEN RESOLVED YET?
>> SO FIRST OF ALL, YOU'RE
RIGHT, THAT WAS A SHOW.
LET THE POLITICAL MARTYRDOM
BEGIN.
THE PROBLEM WITH WHAT HE JUST
DID AND THE REASONS WHY SMART
LAWYERS WILL TELL YOU DON'T SAY
ANYTHING IS HE SORT OF
CONTRADICTED HIMSELF.
BECAUSE HE SAID TWO THINGS.
HE SAID THE REASON I DEFIED THE
SUBPOENA IS BECAUSE IT IS A
POLITICAL WITCH HUNT AND PELOSI
AND THE OTHER NAMES THAT HE
DROPPED AND I'M NOT GOING TO
ALLOW THAT TO HAPPEN.
ALSO I HAVE THIS EXECUTIVE
PRIVILEGE ISSUE SO WHICH ONE IS
IT.
WHAT IS YOUR REASON OR DEFENSE?
THEY DON'T GO WELL TOGETHER.
HIS LAWYER WAS MISCHARACTERIZING
THESE DOJ MEMOS.
TO AN EXTENT.
THERE IS A DOJ MEMO WHICH SAID
IT IS POSSIBLE THAT EXECUTIVE
PRIVILEGE COULD APPLY BEYOND THE
EXECUTIVE BRANCH IN ATTORNEY
NARROW CIRCUMSTANCES.
THAT I DON'T THINK ARE RELEVANT
HERE.
ALSO, THIS IS THE BIG QUESTION
FOR BANNON, HOW IS HE GOING TO
CLAIM EXECUTIVE PRIVILEGE ON
CONVERSATIONS WITH OTHER PEOPLE
NOT IN THE EXECUTIVE BRANCH,
WITH RUDY GIULIANI, WITH THIS
LAWYER JOHN EASTMAN.
HE'S GOING TO HAVE A MAJOR
PROBLEM AND THIS GETS BACK TO
ONE OF THE BIG PROBL